l'espèce animale qui terrorise le plus
les humains est aussi la plus petite
tu laisses mais quelle horreur si ces
petites bêtes devenait vraiment vrai
morts
vraiment énorme je me suis battu avec
une punaise énorme
ah oui quand-même grosses comme finesse
je suis un enfant soeur de punaises
il y en a certaines qui volent
je la clownette apple c'est dégueulasse
alors préparez-vous à l'invasion la plus
surprenante
la plus monstrueuse
j'ai connu bien pire la plus criante
hélas plus démentiel que l'humanité
d'affronter
c'est le
je m'étais pas autant marié depuis la
guerre en irak
je suis ci dessus enfin cité à deux
doigts
les psys